josh shapiro is the democratic candidate  for pennsylvania governor and he tweeted  that he wants to send people a check for  250  for each passenger vehicle that they own  up to four vehicles this is a terrible  idea now i want josh shapiro to defeat  doug mastriano doug mastriano is the  winner of the republican primary for the  pennsylvania governorship he's a lunatic  he's outrageous he's one of these big  lie supporting trumpists he we can't  vote for him  in pennsylvania but i also don't like  this idea from josh shapiro it's only  going to further ingrain fossil fuel  vehicles it encourages people to just  have more vehicles when that might not  be what actually makes sense is it just  me or is this a terrible idea let me  know in the comments